[Música]
[Aplausos]
qué tipo de control crees que tiene
sobre tu futuro
hace un par de años iba caminando por
los pasillos de la universidad con un
amigo mío y muy extraña mente y a un
plano a nuestra siguiente clase
entonces me dijo que si lo acompañaba
por un café yo dije que sí
bajamos a la cafetería y nos encontramos
con una fila inmensa de gente y nos
formamos al cabo teníamos tiempo
pasaron un par de minutos de nosotros en
forma un chavo y una chava
y amigos los conocía entonces los saludo
y me presento yo volteé y pensé que como
tal
alan garcía mucho gusto e inmediatamente
nos hicimos amigos
mientras estábamos en la fila nos dimos
cuenta que mis nuevos amigos y yo
estudiamos la misma carrera y no sólo
eso incluso llevábamos la misma clase
pero en diferentes horarios ellos
estaban en la clase de las once y media
y estaba en la clase de la una
no llegamos a la caja ya me han
convencido de que me cambiara la clase
con ellos yo era nuevo la carrera no
conocía mucha gente entonces no
y me cambia la clase de las once y media
durante el semestre mi relación con
estas dos personas fue creciendo
bastante
eventualmente
se convirtió en una de mis amigos más
cercanos una de las personas más
creativas que conozco y compañero en
bastantes proyectos dentro y fuera de la
universidad
y ella
se convirtió en mi mejor amiga que casi
casi puedo decir que me conoce mejor de
lo que yo me conozco a mí mismo
entonces hace unos meses
me puse a pensar solo sobre lo que había
sucedido ese día
y dije haber tiempo pero que hubiera
pasado así como siempre hubiera llegado
tarde a la universidad que hubieran
pasado si no hubiera acompañado a mi
amigo por su café de verdad no hubiera
conocido estas dos personas que tanto
han influido en mi vida los últimos dos
años
mientras más me pegaba la loquera y una
seguía preguntando más cosas llegué a
esta pregunta en particular
de verdad la pequeña decisión de ir por
un café
influyó de esta manera en mi vida de que
yo conociera estas dos personas que
tanto han influido en mis aprendizajes y
en mis experiencias y eventualmente me
hicieron la persona que soy hoy
con todo esto tuve una clase de
alucinación y antes de decirles cuál fue
quiero presentarles una persona
ese soy yo cuando tenía siete años
y esta alucinación nos involucra a
nosotros dos
y fue que me di cuenta que el lugar
donde estoy en este momento la persona
que soy y el estilo de vida que estoy
llevando es un reflejo de todas las
pequeñas decisiones que he tomado desde
que yo era él
las pequeñas decisiones son importantes
porque nuestro día a día tomamos
muchísimas de ellas
es porque estás se encarga de nuestra
actitud de nuestro humor y nuestra
atención durante el día
son importantes porque cuando se trata
de decisiones que tomamos todos los días
eventualmente éstas se convierten en
nuestros hábitos y nuestros hábitos
definen las personas que somos hoy
no me dicen todo el tiempo
lee 15 minutos al día la escala de un
día no se va a ver como la gran cosa
pero si es algo que decides hacer todos
los días al mes a los tres meses a los
seis meses
cuántos libros crees que vas a haber
leído
son igual de importantes por la
incertidumbre que viene con ellas cuando
las tomamos porque como me pasó a mí no
sabes en qué situación puede llegar a
estar qué persona puedes llegar a
conocer o qué experiencia puedes llegar
a vivir
y esto no necesariamente tiene que ser
visto como algo negativo al contrario
debe ser visto como algo positivo porque
es tomar en cuenta cada vez que tomemos
una decisión la infinidad de escenarios
que se pueden desenvolver y con ellos
todos los aprendizajes que podemos
llegar a adquirir
ahora qué aspectos influyen en nosotros
para tomar decisiones imaginémonos que
este es nuestro cerebro
y dentro de nuestro cerebro yo me lo
imagino así como si fuera una mesa de
discusión donde están todos los aspectos
que influyen en nuestra toma de
decisiones nuestra percepción nuestras
emociones nuestros pensamientos nuestras
experiencias nuestros miedos nuestras
capacidades y nuestras necesidades
dentro de los factores externos están
los factores de riesgo la estabilidad
del entorno y uno bastante común
es la presión social y el miedo que van
a decir las más personas
y yo creo que este aspecto en particular
es fastidiosamente común cuando ni
siquiera debería ser considerado
el error que todos cometemos con este
aspecto es que pensamos que le debemos
una explicación a alguien que justifique
porque hacemos lo que hacemos y nuestras
decisiones
entonces estaba viendo esta mesa de
decisión
y me puse a pensar y dije bueno si este
es un método de toma de decisiones
confiable entonces que estamos haciendo
mal porque no me dejaron mentir porque
sigue habiendo tantas veces que estamos
con gente con la que no nos gusta
convivir en lugares donde no nos gusta
estar y haciendo cosas que no nos gusta
hacer sí o no
entonces me di cuenta
que hay un aspecto muy importante que no
está en esa mesa y debería estar
este aspecto no está allí porque nos
conformamos con nuestras vidas nos da
flojera hacer las cosas y nos quedamos
estancados en la rutina solo aceptando
lo que las demás personas permiten que
la vida no se dé
ese aspecto son nuestras metas
piénselo bien en qué momento empujamos a
nuestras metas fuera de nuestra toma de
decisiones
piénsalo
en qué momento empezamos a ver nuestras
vidas siguiendo el sistema debe a la
preparatoria ve a la universidad
consigue un buen empleo y nuestras metas
en qué momento yo creo que las metas
merecen un lugar en nuestra mesa de toma
de decisiones
porque así pueden empezar a influir en
nuestra vida así podemos dejar de vivir
por etapas y empezaremos a vivir caminos
en nuestros objetivos
con todo esto tuve una clase de
descubrimiento que va a sonar bastante
sencillo y claro que es más fácil
decirlo que hacerlo pero descubrí que
para cumplir nuestras metas
todas las decisiones que tomemos durante
el día tiene que ser dirigidas hacia lo
que queremos lograr y hacia donde
queremos estar
piénsenlo qué pasaría si en todas las
pequeñas decisiones que tomamos durante
el día
reflexionaremos esto como me acerca más
a mi objetivo esto cómo beneficia a mi
trayectoria hacia donde quiero estar y
hace lo que quiero lograr
ahora ya sé lo que están pensando
julián es que no es tan fácil obtener lo
que quieres no es tan fácil llegar a
donde quieres estar si entiendo estoy de
acuerdo hay obstáculos hay imprevistos
incluso
qué pasa cuando no sabes qué es lo que
quieres
piénselo bien
de verdad sabes lo que quieres
de verdad las metas que tienes fueron
puestas ahí por ti o por alguien más
vamos a ponernos a pensar en esto hay
bastantes veces en nuestra vida donde
nos vamos a encontrar en esas
situaciones donde no sabemos qué es lo
que queremos
cuando no nos gustan nuestros jóvenes
podíamos nuestro trabajo cuando no
sabemos qué carrera estudiar o incluso
cuando estás empezando alguna relación
ahora es aceptable no tener metas y es
aceptable no saber qué quieres hacer con
tu vida lo que no es aceptable es no
hacer nada al respecto para encontrarlas
lo mejor que pueda ser una persona que
se encuentra en una situación así es
decirle que sí a las nuevas experiencias
que nos parecen desconocidas o fuera de
lo común
pongamos a pensar lo escuchamos todo el
tiempo si quieres algo que no has tenido
tienes que hacer algo que no has hecho
en el caso estudiar a una carrera hay
bastante gente que dice que los 18 y 19
años eres muy joven para escoger qué
quieres hacer el resto en tu vida y tal
vez sea cierto pero en el momento que
nosotros nos enteramos que en ese
momento vamos a tener que tomar la
decisión es responsabilidad nuestra
estar preparados para ese momento y esto
aplica para todas las grandes decisiones
en cualquier etapa de nuestras vidas en
el momento que sabemos que vamos a tomar
una gran decisión
es responsabilidad nuestra estar
preparados para ese momento y sentirnos
capaces de tomar la decisión
esto va completamente de la mano con el
aprendizaje que le podemos sacar a cada
cosa
un amigo declare siempre dice que
abriendo diferentes puertas
descubrimos diferentes mundos
y si no te gustan las nuevas cosas que
estás haciendo está bien pero si no las
haces te vas a quedar el resto de tu
vida pensando el qué hubiera pasado si
hubiera hecho esto que ha pasado si
hubiera hecho aquello y eso es lo que a
largo plazo nos puede perjudicar y
pensar que no estamos aprovechando
nuestras vidas
mi mamá siempre me dice que no podemos
darnos el lujo de dejar pasar
oportunidades como si tuviéramos
infinitas
les quiero hablar de un enemigo que
tenemos en estas pequeñas decisiones que
tomamos
el enemigo
no son las decisiones tomadas
equivocadamente
el enemigo es la indecisión
cuántas veces nos han dicho es
preferible tomar la decisión incorrecta
a no tomar ninguna decisión en absoluto
porque esta indecisión es la que
llevamos con nosotros todos los días las
que día a día pesan más y más y
eventualmente nos crean conflictos
internos con nuestros pensamientos y
nuestras emociones
y esto perjudica bastante nuestra
capacidad de tomar decisiones nos hace
tener mal temperamento
baja autoestima
hay muchas veces que la frustración de
las personas no es que hayan decidido
equivocadamente es que estuvieron tanto
tiempo en momentos de indecisión que
eventualmente la decisión fue tomada por
alguien más y ellos tuvieron que
conformarse con lo que les tocó y de ahí
viene el arrepentimiento más grande el
despertarte un día y saber que pudiste
haber hecho algo diferente pero no lo
hiciste
porque seguimos tomando decisiones
pequeñas como si no importara
ahorita es el momento de tomar acción y
darnos cuenta del poder que tenemos
sobre nuestra toma de decisiones
y así dirigirlas hacia nuestros
objetivos y hacia lo que lo que queremos
lograr con nuestras vidas
ahora les quiero decir una última cosa
es una reflexión que tuve hace como seis
meses cuando estaba viendo esta pequeña
película que se llama volver al futuro
no sé si la conozcan
y es que porque se nos hace tan lógico
que cuando el personaje principal viaje
al pasado y cambia un pequeño detalle
una pequeña decisión
cambia completamente su vida y la vida
de las personas a su alrededor pero
nosotros en nuestro día a día no
pensamos que una pequeña decisión pueda
cambiar considerablemente nuestras vidas
tenemos que recordar que estamos en
control de nuestro futuro
tenemos que incluir a nuestras metas en
nuestra mesa de toma de decisiones y así
dirigirla siempre hacia donde queremos
estar
tenemos que recordar que todo es una
decisión todo lo que hacemos todo lo que
decimos incluso todo lo que pensamos
es chistoso pensar como todas las
oportunidades y todos los aprendizajes
que se nos presentan en el futuro van a
depender completamente de las pequeñas
decisiones que tomemos hoy
al final asegúrate de haber decidido tu
vida y no de haberte conformado con lo
que alguien más decidió por ti porque
dentro de cinco diez o quince años el
estilo de vida de tus hijos va a
depender completamente de las decisiones
y de los hábitos que empieces a tomar
hoy gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]